hello everyone it's seven o'clock you're
watching Sky News breakfast crisis talks
for the chancellor and the Prime
Minister today a week after a mini
budget which has sent shockwaves through
the economy and piled the pressure on
the government with public support for
the Tories slumping to its lowest level
since the late 1990s
in a few moments we'll get the view of
the financial secretary to the treasury
Andrew Griffith and I'll also speak to
the former deputy governor of the bank
of England sir Charlie Bean it's Friday
the 30th of September
damage control the Prime Minister and
Chancellor prepare to meet the head of
the UK's independent fiscal Watchdog
after a week of turmoil
the talks calm as pressure grows on the
government with labor surging to its
largest lead in the polls in over two
decades
at least 12 people are dead and parts of
Florida destroyed in what's being called
a 500-year flood event as hurricane Ian
continues its path of destruction
hurricane Ian will be casting a dark
shadow for some considerable time over
Florida the Sunshine
president zielinski calls on Russians to
stop their president as Putin prepares
to formally Annex four Ukrainian regions
after what the West has called sham
elections
health check a new survey reveals that
NH star NHS staff are missing meals at
work and some are leaving for better
paid jobs elsewhere
I believe in Liverpool have arrested a
man on suspicion of the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell
also coming up this morning Royal
Rebrand the first coins featuring a
portrait of King Charles are revealed
huge
nail to get the recognition under
respect that we now have as a serious
club not some novels he act I won't go
back and we'll be speaking to the star
of an acclaimed new film about a secret
affair at a fictional gay Rugby Club
[Music]
hello a very good morning to you the
Prime Minister and the chancellor will
meet the head of the UK's independent
fiscal Watchdog today as pressure mounts
on the government after a mini budget
that's rocked financial markets it comes
after a powerful group of cross-party
MPS demanded the chancellor release a
full economic forecast by the end of
October a month earlier than planned
this truss and quasi-quarting have
defended their fiscal policy with the
Prime Minister insisting the government
took decisive action that will Aid
growth
well a new poll highlights the scale of
the crisis facing the Prime Minister it
shows labor 33 points ahead
well it's certainly been an eventful
week economically and politically so
let's take a quick look back at it
and last Friday the chancellor of
quasiquating announced his mini budget
in the Commons promising more tax cuts
on top of a 45 billion pound package
that he announced amid expectations that
borrowing will surge the pound slumped
almost immediately and had fallen to its
lowest level in 37 years by
mid-afternoon
following more fallouts over the weekend
the currency fell close to
1.3 cents early on Monday that's a
record low
late on Tuesday night the international
monetary fund took the rare decision to
urge the government to re-evaluate its
tax cut plan warning it WIll Stoke
Rising inflation and increase inequality
then on Wednesday a major moment when
the bank of England stepped in launching
a 65 billion pound intervention to stop
a run on Pension funds
yesterday the Prime Minister defended
her policy saying they will put the UK
on a better trajectory for the long term
well I'm pleased to say that your
financial secretary to the treasury
Andrew Griffith joins me now Andrew
Griffith good morning to you thanks very
much good morning for talking to us this
morning so the Prime Minister and the
chancellor are on their way to meet the
obr's Richard Hughes today
when was the last time a prime minister
went to meet the obr like this it's
pretty unprecedented isn't it a sign of
the real crisis that we're in
well it seems to be a very good idea
that the Prime Minister and Chancellor
are sitting down with the independent
obr
um just like the Independent Bank of
England you know they've got a really
important role to play we all want the
forecasts to be as quickly as as they
can uh but also as a former Finance
director I know that you also want them
to have the right level of detail so
that that's where we are in that process
we had to act fast because if we hadn't
have acted tomorrow the first of October
was when in Energy prices were going to
rise across the whole United Kingdom uh
damaging businesses and households so we
had to act a week ago today uh it's
really important that we work as we are
handing glove with the Independent Bank
of England and the obr to now uh put the
forecasts in place and move through this
you say you had to act fast you'd
already announced the energy package to
support people with Rising prices you
didn't have to push ahead with a raft of
tax cuts that were unfunded and without
the obr's analysis alongside which would
have shown how much it would cost and
how it was going to be paid for which
might have reassured the markets
well with respect the way it's going to
be paid for is by coming forward with
the plan for growth So the plan for
growth was a detailed set of measures
people needed didn't the markets need to
see the obr spelling that out well
there's 40 pages of detail in the growth
plan I'm sure you've read that and the
obr's read that but there's a lot of
detail to work through there's a very
significant set of supply-side measures
to help the economy there's measures to
help prevent strikes that are just
grinding this country uh to a halts we
we've heard this week the labor party
want to give more rights to people to
strike within our growth plan is
reducing the right to strike so that we
can keep the economy moving so with
respect if all we've done is come up
with just the energy measures important
and critical And Timely though they were
then you'd be sitting here asking us how
we're going to get the economy growing
the obr wouldn't be able to reflect that
economic plan in their numbers as well
that's what the markets want to hear
they want to hear that we're all work
working tightly together as we are I
think the chancellor and the bank of
England Governor have spoken every day
this week okay but also how we can put
the credible plans in place uh that we
need going forward so if you accept that
the markets need to see the government
and the obr working close together do
you accept then it was a mistake not to
release an assessment from the obr at
the same time as the mini budget yes or
no
well Anna the obr at that point wouldn't
have had access to the growth plan well
they confirmed last night that they
could have produced a forecast in time
for the mini budget well that forecast
wouldn't have had the growth measures in
that plan that they would have been
finalized in the hours before the
chancellor stood up it was right that he
did that first in Parliament and there's
a very significant amount of supply side
measures that now over the coming weeks
and have said before as quickly as
possible but in as much detail as
necessary to give the credibility to
those plans that the obr will want to be
reflecting that significant supply side
reform you know getting our energy uh
new the the transition to a new clean
energy uh going at real Pace uh building
some of the infrastructure that hasn't
been built for many years making sure
that we're bringing more affordable
housing to the market you've got to look
at all of that in the round and the the
forecast the OVR could have produced in
advance would have been a static
forecast that wouldn't have had the
ability to reflect the growth plan that
the Chancellor's brought forward okay so
there's this meeting going on today with
the obr will we see a report from them
ahead of that November the 23rd day that
the chancellor has given us so far will
that be brought forward
well I think Anna the point about an
independent obr is that they've got to
be given the freedom and ability to do
that I'm sure if they could they they
would and that's a decision for them uh
but it's not for me or anyone else to
dictate that to them
so we might get one before if the obr
decides to produce one that's what
you're saying well what I'm saying is is
we've got to respect the independent obr
and and with respect I'm not coming on
Sky News to to tell or ask the obr what
to do it's a shared Endeavor we need to
provide the the necessary detail of our
plans that's what we are focused on uh
and then the obr will want to do do
their job and do that with the right
degree of diligence uh to be able to
come up with their forecasts it's not
easy there are lots of moving Parts uh
controlling Infamous inflation is not
easy uh the impacts of the supply chain
of Putin's aggression in Ukraine is
cascading through many parts of the
economy government's got a comprehensive
set of measures designed to deal with
the immediate crisis in energy and to
grow the economy thereafter uh going
into this you know remember we we start
this in a strong position we have the
second lowest level of debt to GDP of
any of the G7 Nations and our economy is
strong resilient and flexible and yet
we've had Chaos on the market we've seen
the the pound slump we've seen chaos in
the bond market as well that has seen an
unprecedented move by the bank of
England to intervene what did spook the
market what would you say the reason was
now
well we've seen difficulties in in lots
of international markets this week uh
obviously the the UK has been quite
um challenging uh but the German
inflation figures that came out
yesterday were an unprecedented
unprecedented level of German inflation
11 that's the highest uh since the
single currency uh ever came to being I
suspect it's one of the highest uh in
German history earlier this week we saw
the Nordstrom pipeline that this time
last year would have been putting 160
million cubic liters of gas coming from
Russia uh to Europe to help power all of
our energy
um you know yes yesterday there were
zero liters of gas coming through that
pipeline so we're in a period you've got
to look a little bit about the wider
context that we're in okay well you
you're still saying that it's down to
Global pressures but Hugh pill who's the
bank of England's Chief economy Anna I
agree with you and he he was very clear
that there's
um this is
that's not fair to misrepresent Hugh
Hugh is very clear that this is
something that all major Global
economies are seeing
um of course this particular week we've
we've seen more movement in the UK than
others but if we look overall at the
trajectory of interest rates for example
going into this week the UK had seen a
lower increase in interest rates uh than
most other major economies now there's
been a degree of of catching up well yes
he talked about the global picture but
he said there is undoubtedly a UK
specific component and and there are
there are members of the of the
conservative party who are unhappy with
the way the government is putting this
solely down to Global issues
um we've got Lord Frost saying today if
they want to establish confidence with
the markets ministers must be honest in
what they say yes Global conditions are
part of the story but it's obvious last
week's statement caused the crash we've
got Julian Smith MP former Chief whip
the government must scrap 45p take
responsible ability for the link between
last Friday and the impact on people's
mortgages and make clear that it will do
everything possible to stabilize markets
and protect public services do you
accept what they say there
and what I'd say to colleagues is you
know this is a difficult time for all
all developed economies and and for all
governments this is a government that's
taken uh decisive steps to deal with the
immediate energy crisis and I would just
ask people to look at what the
opposition party has been saying they've
been up in Liverpool this week uh the
biggest Round of Applause they had was
for the nationalization of an energy
company they've committed themselves to
increase the energy insecurity of this
country by turning off every last cubic
meter of North Sea gas by 2030 I think
that's the wrong decision and then
tomorrow we're going to see another wave
of national strikes this government
wants to reduce the ability of Strikers
to bring this country to a halt uh the
labor party want to give them more
rights okay let me talk a little bit
about spending because there's going to
be a huge uh squeeze on public spending
it isn't there not least because of
inflation rising at the levels that it
is
will benefits rise in line with
inflation can we be clear and clarify
that position
well this is the government that's on
the side of the most vulnerable you saw
that in the cost of living measures that
we brought forward this this earlier the
richest benefited most from the memory
every household will get 400 pounds but
the most vulnerable 8 million will get 1
200 pounds so I think you can look at
our actions there there'll be a normal
operating process that's followed
that'll make those decisions in due
course so again that's not one for this
morning Anna but that normal process
will go through none of these choices
are easy uh the biggest fiscal
intervention that this government has
made is that energy package that means
from Tomorrow the first of October when
bills would otherwise be going up the
bill for the average household uh will
now be around 2 500 pound that's
significantly less and it's giving
everybody in the economy businesses and
households the confidence to get on and
do what they need to do just
why why is it possible to announce a a
cut in the top rate of income tax for
the richest people but it's not possible
to confirm whether or not benefits will
rise with inflation I don't understand
why one decision can be made the other
one we have to wait for but there's a
normal there's a normal process around
the annual round of how benefits are
uprighted
um that's not something that habitually
and normally they would rise with
inflation normally one wouldn't sit here
at 7 14 on Sky News with respect Anna
and announce the uh the normal up rating
package for benefits that'll be for
ministers and secretaries of state to
decide over the coming weeks using the
normal process
and what about the squeeze on on public
services there are some suggesting that
given the the commitments that have been
made as far as tax cuts are concerned uh
given at the rise in inflation there's
going to have to be a real squeeze and
it could be in line with the the
austerity measures that we saw those
years ago
well that's speculation what I know
because what has been said by the
chancellor is that he's absolutely
committed to the current spending round
the comprehensive spending round uh
that's been in place for some time now
um and he's confirmed that he's not
reopening that so that will see Public
Services continue to be funded uh
consistent with what's in that spending
review
what do you make of this latest poll
that's come out the yougov poll that
gives labor a 33 point lead that would
suggest if there was an election
tomorrow there'd be a Tory Wipeout it
has this government already lost the
confidence of the public
well the public will decide that but
what I would use that poll as as a
reason to look in detail at Labor's
policies
um customers citizens across the country
that aren't going to get their posts
delivered tomorrow that aren't going to
be able to take the train to work or
visit family can make their view about
whether the thing that the country needs
is more rights for striking workers
whether when a lot of our economic
challenges and headwinds are due to the
lack of energy in security I mean the
exception here is the dollar the dollar
is very strong because the U.S has great
energy security and energy Independence
we don't we're on that Journey this
government's done a great deal to bring
more renewable energy to come forward I
don't think what we need when we're
trying to attract more investment into
our renewable clean energy sector it is
a nationalized Energy company that will
deter that investment or a a virtue
signaling commitment to turn off every
last drop of North Sea gas by 2030 that
will put us make us more vulnerable as
an economy that's what we heard from
labor this week if that's what people
want uh then they they know where to get
it I don't think that's what's right for
our economy
party conference starts this weekend
doesn't it how difficult do you think
it's going to be going in with poll
leads like that for labor and with a
number of Tory MPS fairly unhappy about
the direction the government's taken so
far
well I'm really looking forward to the
conservative conference looking forward
to hearing from all of the secretary's
estate the exciting sell side supply
side reforms in their area whether
that's improving child care whether it's
building more homes more affordable
homes in the right places whether it's
looking at how we can really unleash the
potential of the economy uh science and
Innovation superpower I'm very excited
you look across the uh the piece if you
if you look through the 40 pages of this
growth plan about how we're going to get
the economy growing again I think
there's a lot of detail there and I'm
looking forward to some of that being
revealed next week okay well Andrew
Griffith we appreciate your time this
morning thanks uh very much indeed for
joining us thank you very much thank you
so let's take a look now at how the
growing pressure on the government is
playing out in the morning papers and uh
the guardian first of all leads with the
upcoming meeting between the Prime
Minister Liz truss and Richard Hughes
their headline PM holds crunch talks
with Watchdog over fiscal chaos
the eye has more on the market crisis
warning of atori Wipeout after a new
poll suggests that more than half of
Voters would back the labor party in a
general election
and that record poll is also featured on
the front of the Metro the headline
labor lead Tories by 33 points the
party's largest lead in almost three
decades
economic turmoil is also covered by The
Daily Telegraph with a focus on benefit
payments which are set to full
despiteless trust's attempts to stem the
bleeding
and here's at the times of the similarly
their headline defiant PM set to curb
benefits to fund budget
the peaceful death of the queen is on
the front of the express as new details
emerge after the release of Her
Majesty's death certificate
let me just bring you a little bit of
breaking news now that's coming into us
on house prices uh let's bring in Sky's
Adele Robinson to find out more so Adele
what can you tell us about house prices
then what's this breaking news
okay
um these are figures that have been
released by the country's largest London
Nationwide and what they are showing is
what they've described as a modest
slowing in-house price growth um I think
the overall picture here is that the
housing market is playing a slow game of
catch-up with the economy
um growth softened again in September
um going from 10 in August down to 9.5
percent uh this month and that's the
first time that it's hit single digits
since October of last year
um overall Nationwide has said that the
pace does remain robust but and it's a
big but when you take into account
seasonal changes
um the month and month uh price change
for uh house prices is actually it was
remained the same so in real terms
prices are the same and that's the first
time that that's happened since July of
last year but you can't look at these
figures in isolation of course there
have been signs over the last few months
that the housing market is slowing
there's an emerging picture overall that
new new buyer inquiries are down at the
number of mortgage approvals are also
falling and add into the mix the highest
interest rate the bank imposed a few
weeks ago of 2.25 for 14 years also some
forecasters saying that it's set to rise
to up to six percent by Spring over next
year and and the biggest issue I think
is a lot has changed in the last week is
the affordability for people for
homeowners for those uh who want to buy
for those who are remortgaging so the
bigger picture is fairly gloomy you're
talking about buyer power and confidence
so the deterioration of the Econo the
economic
um the economy picture is yet to be
taken into full consideration with
regards to these figures things like an
energy inflation uh mortgage deals being
taken off the market in their hundreds
we'll see what happens with that today
um so overall I think that we can see
over over the next few months
potentially that picture catching up
with the economy but it's not
necessarily
um all doom and gloom there is some hope
they describe these figures as robust
and as long as the labor market remains
strong that will help things they also
suggest that low housing stock as well
might help things along too and
potentially the stamp Duty as well if
that's not being offset by other factors
as we've seen in the last week
Adele thanks very much indeed
do you stay with us we've got lots more
coming up for you on the show this
morning as the Fallout from the
Chancellor's mini budget continues I'm
going to be joined by the former deputy
governor of the bank of England to
Charles Bean
then as another round of rail strikes
Loom we'll be discussing how to avoid
travel chaos this weekend with the rail
delivery group
and then after eight o'clock I'm going
to be joined by Labor's Shadow business
secretary Jonathan Reynolds
[Music]
but let's go to Florida now where at
least 12 people have died after
Hurricane Ian pummeled the state
President Joe Biden warned it could be
the deadliest hurricane in Florida's
history with early reports of
substantial loss of life our U.S
correspondent James Matthews has this
report
hurricane Ian may have moved on but it's
left its mark
there are scenes like this across the
state of Florida
this picture from Pelican Bay a vivid
example of Nature's ferocity
here Boats were carried by a so-called
storm surge over power lines 20 feet
high
not before one had taken the second
story of this boat rental building and
the wind and water wrecked everything
else there's a bar boat there which is a
bar so you come up and have drinks
that's gone Paul Boucher had built this
business over 20 years in 20 hours it
was gone so it's heartbreaking it's
nothing I mean money is money but it's a
work and labor of love that we all put
into this place and now it's gone
this category 4 hurricane measured more
than 30 miles wide the damage at left
should its devastating power
this had been a Causeway linking Sanibel
Island with the Florida Mainland no
longer
millions of people Statewide were caught
up in the danger posed by 150 mile an
hour winds
[Music]
the town of Naples was caught in the
Hurricane's cross Hills as they cleaned
up here they were called A Night Under
Siege the guys are pushing the truck out
of of the bay this had been the scene at
the town's fire station at the height of
the hurricane the building itself was
flooded leaving one fire Appliance out
of action the water came up fast and I
think it started to affect the
electrical system the chief showed us
the damage and shared his despair I have
33 years on the job and to not be able
to go and help when we're called just
eats that chick
an added complication with this
hurricane is a rip through this state
was the pace at which it moved it was
slow and so it caused damage over an
extended period it's also prevented
rescue teams from taking to the road and
reaching people in danger
in nipples they've been recording these
historic scenes tourists in their own
time the landmark Pier Bears the scars
of hurricane Ian across this town and
this state it has been a tough ride
James Matthews Sky News Florida
and James sent us this update from Fort
Myers Beach in Florida
you join me in the getaway Marina just
next to palcon Bay very popular this
part of Florida with tourists with
fishermen they used to congregate here
this used to be a two-story office where
boats would be rented there was a coffee
shop behind as you can see it's only one
story now the second story was removed
buy a boat a boat carried on the water
what happened was the boats in Falcon
Bay were carried by the storm surge
created by Hurricane Ian lifted 12 feet
and more in the air and taken that way
at a height that got them across the
power lines and you can see in the
distance just in amongst the trees those
extremely expensive boats that were
carried on the water and they lie there
abandoned on the other side of the road
they're also on this side of the road
and you can see you get a sense of the
the scale of Destruction boats debris
carried like toys by the power of
Hurricane Ian and this will take months
and many years to repair and that's a
situation duplicated across this state
hurricane Ian will be casting a dark
shadow for some considerable time over
Florida the Sunshine State
James Matthews reporting there also
making news this morning a 34 year old
man has been arrested on suspicion of
the murder of nine-year-old Olivia Pratt
Corbell Olivia was killed in dovecut in
Liverpool on the 22nd of August after a
gunman fired shots into her home at
about 10 o'clock in the evening as he
was chasing another man police say the
investigation is ongoing and gay and
appealed for people with information to
come forward
energy bills are increasing for Millions
from Tomorrow new research from
uswitch.com showed that 20 of homes will
need to cut their use of energy to be
able to afford the bills this winter the
rising cost has led to nearly nine in
ten making a change around their homes
to prepare for the winter and the
expected cost rise the government's
energy price guarantee caps a typical
household bill at 2 500 pounds
the Queen's cause of death has been
listed on her death certificate as old
age National records of Scotland
published the Queen's entry in the
register of deaths it says she died at 3
10 p.m on the 8th of September the
document lists the former monarchs
occupation as her majesty the queen it
was signed by the Queen's daughter the
Princess Royal
to the war in Ukraine now and Vladimir
Putin is set to host a ceremony annexing
four regions of Ukraine following
referendums widely denounced as a sham
and ahead of the announcement Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski used his
nightly address to call on Russian
citizens to stop their president
everyone in the world understands well
what such an attempt to annexation will
actually mean it will not mean what the
Kremlin hopes for
eign
but to stop this you will have to stop
the one in Russia who once War more than
life your life the citizens of Russia
well International correspondence Alex
Rossi is in Moscow Forest this morning
so Moscow works at Moscow Alex we're
expecting a big announcement from Moscow
later from President Putin what exactly
is he going to say
well we are told by his spokesman Anna
that his speech will be voluminous so we
can expect a very uh long detailed
speech possibly ranting possibly
paranoid we've heard that kind of thing
before about how NATO is using the
government in Kiev the Nazi government
in Kiev as a proxy to destroy Russia and
that is why Vladimir Putin has had no
choice but to Annex these regions in
terms of the choreography there's going
to be an enormous amount of pageantry
Celebration glorifying The Nation as
these areas are absorbed into the
motherland a 3 P.M Moscow time Vladimir
Putin will sign the treaties that will
mean the annexation is moving into law
it will have to go through the Russian
Parliament both chambers of that the
Constitutional Court as well so there'll
be a lot of hyper legalistic stuff as
well in the upside down world of Putin's
Russia the law is everything it gives it
veneer of legitimacy but of course these
referenda we shouldn't even call them
referenda the so-called referendum the
pseudo-referenda are a sham they've been
taking place in areas that Russia has
taken through uh Conquest areas that
incidentally it doesn't even control all
of politically or military militarily
the areas we're talking about about 40
000 square miles about the size of
Portugal so a huge chunk of Ukraine
about 15 percent of the country but what
it does mean for Vladimir Putin is it
gives him a strength to the argument
that he's been making already that this
isn't just a limited war that Russia is
fighting it is now fighting an
existential War
um the west and Ukraine are trying to
take parts of the motherland it's an
attack on Russia which helps with the
mobilization effort here which has been
profoundly unpopular when it comes to
that when you aggregate all the people
that have left the country these are men
of 5 age about two hundred thousand so
that's more than the number that started
in the initial Invasion so it
strengthens his hand in that but it also
escalates as well with the West because
once these areas are absorbed into
Russia Russia can legally use all
weapons at its disposal to protect them
including nuclear weapons they fall
under Russia's nuclear
umbrella so there's an element of
nuclear uh blackmail here as well but it
won't do any good you heard from
Vladimir zielinski the Ukrainian
president they are going to continue
trying to take back the land that is
theirs that was taken by an invading
force and I don't think it will Dent
Western support either
Alex thanks very much indeed
now a new survey has found NHS nurses
are skipping meals to feed and clothe
their children and staff are finding it
hard to make the journey to work due to
the rising cost of living one mental
health nurse Victoria told us she's
struggling with the cost of living and
child care costs in particular
and sometimes I end up having to tell my
son we're not buying this today or let's
say uniform or shoes will buy it next
month I might end up in a position
whereby
um either I'll have no money at all and
I would have to look of no money for
food then I would have to actually maybe
go in and find out if I can get
um help and get food vouchers in order
to go to a food bank
let's bring in our correspondent Matthew
Thompson and it's a story that we're
we're hearing quite often now isn't it
Matthew
it is I mean right across Society but I
think this survey reveals really starkly
for the first time this scale of the
impact of the cost of living crisis on
NHS staff you heard their nurses
skipping meals at work in order that
they can feed their own children the
survey also find that staff absences in
the NHS are spiking towards the end of
the month because some staff are simply
unable to afford the travel costs to get
to work in the days before payday and in
fact the situation is so severe the
survey fund but many lower paid members
of NHS staff Health Care assistants
Porters and the like are leaving the
health service for better paid jobs in
other sectors like hospitality and shops
in fact 68 of the NHS trusts that
responded to this survey reported severe
or significant impacts from staff
leaving their jobs and if we add that to
another analysis by the nuffield trust
Healthcare think tank out today which
shows around one in nine nurses left the
Health Service was in the last year for
reasons like burnout and stress and you
can see how we could quickly be on the
verge of something of a staffing crisis
within the NHS and NHS providers which
represents NHS trusts across the country
and did this survey they have called for
realism from the government in the face
of what they called below inflation pay
increases for staff this year now the
government has said in a statement that
we know NHS staff are struggling with
the cost of living pressures and we've
given over 1 million NHS staff a pay
rise of at least 1 400 pounds in line
with the recommendations of the Indian
independent pay review body Frontline
staff they say have access to 40
Nationwide Health and well-being hubs
backed by 45 million pounds in 2022-23
and they finish we've commissioned NHS
England to develop a long-term Workforce
plan to recruit and train more staff and
we know that the government has been
Keen to try and uplift the numbers of
nurses and doctors in the last couple of
years but if increasing numbers are
leaving at a faster rate then they can
be hired well the recruitment process is
running to stand still or even worse
falling behind leaving leading to staff
shortages
Matthew thanks very much indeed
still here on Sky News breakfast I'll be
talking more about the financial turmoil
and be joined by the former deputy
governor of the bank of England Sir
Charles Bean
foreign
[Music]
the financial secretary to the treasury
Andrew Griffith has told this program
it's really important that the
government works with the bank of
England and the office for Budget
responsibility against the backdrop of a
turbulent week for the economy I asked
Mr Griffith about this trust and
quasi-quarters meeting with the
independent fiscal Watchdog later today
it seems to be a very good idea that the
Prime Minister and Chancellor are
sitting down with the independent obr
just like the Independent Bank of
England you know they've got a really
important role to play we all want the
forecasts to be as quickly as they can
but also as a former Finance director I
know that you also want them to have the
right level of detail so that that's
where we are in that process we had to
act fast because if we hadn't of acted
tomorrow the first of October was when
in Energy prices were going to rise
across the whole United Kingdom damaging
businesses and households so we had to
act a week ago today it's really
important that we work as we are handing
glove with the Independent Bank of
England and the obr to now put the
forecasts in place and move through this
well joining me now is the former deputy
governor of the bank of England sir
Charlie Bean a very good morning to you
thanks so much for talking to us this
morning
first of all I want to get your take on
this meeting with the obr by the Prime
Minister and Chancellor you were on the
obr's committee just how unusual is it
for a prime minister to visit the head
of the obr
um well I should emphasize it's uh the
chairman of the obr visiting uh Downing
Street not the other way around but uh
it's unusual for there to be
um meetings with the Prime Minister uh
there's regular meetings with the
chancellor both of the chairman of the
committee uh alone
and the three members of the What's
called the budget responsibility
Committee of which I was a member
um during the course of preparations for
a budget another major fiscal uh events
um this particular meeting obviously is
quite unusual and the context for it is
quite unusual
do you welcome it happening
from it well I welcome it happening but
there is an element of
um closing the stable door after the
horse is bolted clearly one of the
factors that has contributed to the
market turmoil after the
um fiscal event last Friday was the
absence of any accompanying assessment
of the overall state of the public
finances uh which is what the obr is uh
obliged to provide twice a year
uh normally I'm a side alongside the
budget and uh major
um fiscal uh events
um
if all the government had announced last
Friday was the energy price guarantee
the things that were designed to protect
households and businesses about the
consequences of high energy prices
driven by events in Ukraine
um I don't think there would have been a
problem
um they're not being an accompanying obr
forecast because those support measures
are intended to be temporary and will be
self-terminating when uh energy
wholesale Energy prices fall back the
thing that created the problem in my
view was the fact alongside that uh the
chancellor chose to announce the rolling
back of National Insurance uh increase
um and the slated increase in corporate
income taxes I wish you soon I could put
in place to pay for extra Health
spending and those were intended to be
permanent so they potentially have
implications for the sustainability of
the public finances
um now uh this trust during the
leadership campaign have claimed that
the 30 billion Headroom that was
available to the chancellor in March
could be used to finance those uh I my
very strong tuition given the
deterioration in uh economic
circumstances since the spring is that
that uh Headroom is no longer there and
in all probability there would be a
shortfall
so the um the extra elements announced
last week have just simply worsened that
shortfall and will need to be addressed
somehow uh quite possibly by uh cutting
government spending
yes and so what's the implications of
that do you think for spending on public
services
well
um if until we actually see the treasury
figuring and know what the chancellors
uh time Horizon is for getting the debt
to GDP ratio back onto a sustainable
path
um precisely what what is required will
be unclear but given the scale of the
um tax cuts in the event last Friday uh
it's pointing to substantial cuts in
government spending and it should be
said that they would be taking place
against a set of cash limits which were
Set uh a year ago uh which assumed
relatively low inflation that made no
allowance for the fact that inflation
energy costs and so forth are
substantially higher so even
accommodating what's happened within the
existing cash limits would be extremely
demanding
um uh The Institute for fiscal Studies
have suggested uh that they need to be
raised uh significantly by you know the
order of 20 billion a year uh to even
just to compensate for the Direct
effects of the higher inflation on the
costs of government doing business so to
actually reduce public spending in these
circumstances is very demanding
um and it's all the order uh I think of
what we saw during the
um uh the the first uh first few years
of the uh well I guess it's the
coalition government uh from 2010 to uh
2015.
the austerity is is what you're saying
yeah
and what about interest rates what's
your forecast for how high they could go
given the rates of inflation we're
seeing now and seeing some of the
pressures on that rate
I think it's very difficult to uh to
make concrete forecasts of uh exactly
where they will go because it depends on
how economic circumstances unfold
obviously depends on uh what happens to
growth and more particularly inflation
what the bank is concerned about is that
the high level of current inflation
doesn't get embedded in the system
uh with higher wages higher prices
higher inflation expectations in the
future we don't know how strong those
so-called second round effects will be
so the bank will be monitoring uh them
as they unfollow what is clear though I
think without any doubt is that bank
rate has to rise substantially
more from where it is at the moment
um and the bank even before the fiscal
announcement last week had indicated
that that was the case and that interest
rates would continue to rise for a while
uh so I think we're looking at a minimum
of something in the four percent range
uh some people in the markets are
conjecturing retires six
I wouldn't say it's impossible
um personally I suspect it won't need to
go as high as that because there will be
enough slowing in the economy anyway uh
to moderate those second round effects
which they Bank are so worried about
so Charlie being very interesting to get
your take on events of this week and
what it means for the future as well
thanks very much indeed for your time we
really appreciate it you're welcome
so lots of chew over with our political
correspondent Rob Powell very good
morning to you bro nice to see you so
we've heard from the government this
morning and we've also just heard from
uh former bank of England Deputy
Governor
where are we at the end of a turbulent
week I think on this issue of
reassurance for the markets listening to
both sir Charlie bean and Andrew
Griffith it's clear that Charlie Bean
puts some of the unsettling effect of
that mini Budget on Friday down to the
lack of independent scrutiny that came
alongside it usually with a statement
like that you would get the office for
Budget responsibility that would map out
what the borrowing plans would mean to
the economy what the plans could mean
for growth and essentially tied all
together and scrutinize it and it's sort
of an independent eye to almost check
the working if you like I think the fact
that that wasn't their unsettled a lot
of people and the fact that we had a
weekend where the chancellor said look
there could be more to come has
unsettled markets as well so what we're
getting from the government now to an
extent is an attempt to sort of reassure
through having this meeting with the
office a bunch of responsibility I
thought it was interesting Andrew
Griffith suggesting that potentially you
could get a piece of work a forecast
from the obr ahead of that November a
statement he didn't rule that out he
said if they wanted to do it more
quickly then they certainly
um would the danger is as Charlie Bean
said there could this be closing the day
stable door after the horse is bolted
the other side of this I think is about
what these tax cuts will mean for the
amount that government spends on public
services and if there are to be Cuts
where those will fall you questioned
Andrew Griffith about whether benefits
will be upgraded by the rate of
inflation next year so if you were going
off the rate of inflation this Autumn
that could mean almost a 10 rise he said
the normal process would be going
through now that isn't a guarantee and
the normal process could mean that it
has changed to something like earnings
which would be a lot lower so I think
that would be a difficult political
point for the government to be in
essentially cutting taxes for the very
wealthy but then cutting benefits for
the poorest now the Royal Mint has
confirmed that coins featuring a
portrait of King Charles III will
gradually enter circulation from
December the king's image will appear on
50p coins first and then will be
followed by a commemorative five pound
coin featuring two new portraits of the
lake Queen our Royal correspondent
Rhianna Mills reports
it's a huge change after 70 years of his
mother's face looking back at us her son
now takes her place facing the opposite
direction to the queen as is traditional
when there's a mnemonic the Effigy of
King Charles III features on two
Memorial pieces a five pound coin and a
50 pence coins that also still feature
the queen it was really important to us
that the king had input to this design
so working very closely with not just
the designer Martin Jennings but also
having sign off with the King himself to
make sure there was a seamless
empathetic way to end Her Majesty's
Reign and to actually signal the new
reign of a new king because on the back
you have here we go his mother's yeah
face we have the two images of her
majesty herself beginning and end of
ring
designed by sculptor Martin Jennings
using photographs it was only signed off
by the king this month and shows what
some might say is a softer less
obviously Regal image than previous
monarchs these coins are so special that
I've been told I cannot touch them you
might end up being lucky enough to get
one of these 50 pencils because they are
going into circulation but in terms of
the king's face appearing on all of our
money that is not going to happen
anytime soon when the Queen's father
died his coins were still used and now
mother and son will in essence
co-circulate alongside each other Mary
gillick the artist wanted to put a
wreath around Elizabeth's head which is
a very traditional thing on coinage
portraits and when she had a sitting
with the queen she said this to
Elizabeth and Elizabeth II said well
please don't make me look too much like
Julius Caesar what's the comment she
made back an incredible character
forever immortalized in our money with
around 27 billion coins still in
circulation and equally remembered by a
son who feels that all this change
should not overshadow her Rihanna Mills
Sky News in central London